hey this is one of those like fake
setups hey i'm here
but let's just keep in mind no editing
hey guys uh first and foremost what i'm
doing right now is
thank you so much before anything else
for all the communication
i'm just so thankful for all the emails
and tweets and facebook statuses
by the way the facebook stuff is really
easy to communicate with best
facebook.com
gary g-a-r-y come say hey come say hey
and say that you saw this video i'd love
to say hi
i have some time tonight after the i'm
thinking lizito play gotta spend time
with the family number one i want to
talk about something it's funny this is
probably getting passed around because i
think this is actually
good good thought and all that stuff in
the beginning is going to kind of
confuse them so
just how i do it folks it's just real
it's all i know
social media worst thing that ever
happened to social media is the word
media i want to talk about that for a
second because the word media is in
there
um now that i've spent over a year with
vaynermedia spending a lot of times
with different clients and different
agencies everybody wants metrics
everybody wants roi and i think that's
extremely valid and i get it and
ironically there's plenty of things like
hootsuite and
sprinkler and radiant six and nielsen's
has its own version
social media you know stats are out
there hold on justin don't leap
i know it's your anniversary don't leave
um but i think the worst thing that ever
happened to social media
is this word media because what i do
doesn't feel a whole lot like media you
know what i do with
our clients like the nhl and the nets
and the jets
that have been successful in this space
um are doing what brands like zappos and
starbucks and forbes
uh ford excuse me and uh and and uh
comcast and other brands that have
gotten credit or some love
old spice for being involved in this
whole thing are doing doesn't feel a
whole lot like media to me
it really doesn't you know it feels like
customer service
it feels like giving a crap and and i'm
really curious
it's one of these things that i'm really
remember when like you would call the
internet the world wide web
i have a funny feeling and the reason i
called mott we just taped a bunch of
wine library tv i'm not getting here
i have a weird feeling that social media
is going to be rebranded i really do
i just don't feel like it's going to be
called social media now it feels like
social media to me where
one of the big things that we're doing
uh with a lot of clients is we're
extending their media meaning
we're taking the banner ads we're taking
the print and the radio and the
television campaigns and we're extending
the story
into the web and that feels a little
social media like to me you know you're
taking
the creative and you're making it more
engaging you're sending it somewhere
where you're collecting the data and
you're interacting
has a lot of value but it doesn't feel
like media when you're answering
people's question
because i never saw a television
commercial or a billboard
or a newspaper article answer a question
or help with a return or
give a reason you got it okay murph you
got it
i'm sorry you're gonna be mad for the
but there's a lot going on it just never
felt to me as to what i've been doing as
media
i've done media my whole life i bought
billboards i bought banner ads i bought
newspaper ads
what i've been doing for last four years
for my brand for my company for my show
and now for my
clients doesn't feel like media to me i
just think the word is wrong
i you know and i i just predict that
it's going to uh
change and i think that it's really
hurting a lot of people and i think a
lot of agencies and a lot of pr
companies
and a lot of brand managers and a lot of
companies need to think about this
thought
i'm actually a little bit disappointed
that this was so scatterbrained because
it's going to confuse a lot of people
but i i hope you get the genesis and the
thesis of this conversation which is
that
social media is misbranded and by its
terminology it's confusing people
they're trying to find out the roi
which is great but it's the same roi as
earned media and guerrilla marketing
you know chatter is gonna cause some
sales
and you're gonna be able to tie that in
and that's coming but i think what's
much more important is
what's the roi on your relationship with
your best friend
you know i'm curious about that what's
the roi on opening the door for
a woman who's holding two bags or when a
lady gets on
a train you getting up and giving her
that seat what's the roi of manners
what's the roi of
actually carrying that extra thank you
that extra hello smiling
at the register what's the roi